How similar are Japanese and Korean?
The.
Hold on.
Okay.
Now we can start.
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
How similar our Japanese and Korean.
That is the question of the day.
Japan and Korea are geographically very
close to each other and at first glance
they look like similar countries with
similar cultures in a way,
but just how similar are the Japanese
and Korean languages?
Well,
the short answer is they are closer to
each other than they are to any other
languages and they are remarkably
similar in some ways,
but in other ways they're also very
different and they are certainly not
mutually intelligible.
Disclaimer,
I don't speak very much Korean,
but I do speak Japanese and I am aware
of the differences and similarities
between them.
Let's look at the similarities in terms
of grammar,
vocabulary,
pronunciation,
and the writing systems.
When it comes to syntax and grammar,
Japanese and Korean are very similar.
Japanese and Korean sentences can often
be translated word by word with each
word in one sentence,
having an equivalent in the other.
Let's look at a couple of Korean and
Japanese sentences side by side,
and we can see the similarities.
Again,
I don't really speak much Korean,
so with my pronunciation is terrible.
Koreans,
please forgive me in English,
I am a student in Korean.
None.
Then huck saying either in Japanese,
what Tashi duck say this.
You can see that these sentences are
translatable word by word that each word
in the first sentence has an equivalent
in the second sentence in the exact same
position,
so if they are directly translatable.
One thing I want to point out is the
topic marker.
That's the second word.
In each of these sentences,
that topic,
Margaret,
is something that's kind of unique to
Japanese and Korean topic.
Marker points out the topics of a
sentence that's different from the
grammatical subject,
the overarching focus or topic of the
sentence.
Another thing I want to point out is the
last word.
In each sentence.
In Korean it's EDA and in Japanese it's
destitute.
In both cases that's like a popular,
like the word is in English,
so in both Japanese and Korean.
This is a standalone word that is placed
usually at the end of the sentence in
Korean and undone in Japanese.
What does you up and easily will know me
much,
so again,
we see that the topics marker is the
second word in each sentence,
but a more important thing that I want
to point out here is the Sov word order.
That means subject,
object,
verb,
so we can see that the subject is what?
Touchy or it's not in Korean,
and then we have the object next to the
object is water.
In Korean it's and in Japanese it's
music and then we have the verb at the
end.
So in Korean law seemed that Indian
Japanese nomi must,
but before the verb there is an
interesting little word that we don't
have an English and that is an object
marker.
So that's another thing that we find in
both Japanese and Korean used in exactly
the same way in exactly the same
position in the census,
even though the grammar and sentence
structure of the two languages is
remarkably similar,
the vocabulary is remarkably different.
If a Japanese speaker heard Korean
without any prior exposure,
they probably wouldn't understand any of
the words at all or maybe just a word
here and there,
but that doesn't mean that those words
aren't related.
Korean and Japanese both inherited a
large number of loan words from Chinese.
Approximately 60 percent of the
vocabulary in either language comes from
Chinese.
If there are so many Chinese loan words
in both languages,
then why are they not mutually
comprehensible?
Well,
it's important to note that for both
languages in daily conversation and
informal speech,
that Chinese loan words are not used
nearly as much as they are in writing.
Also,
the Chinese loan words are different in
either language to enter the languages
in the form of Chinese characters,
but the pronunciation of those
characters became adapted to fit the
phonological system of either language.
So let's look at some examples.
The first example is just the name of
those Chinese characters themselves.
In Chinese,
in Korean,
I'm job in Japanese Kanji so you can see
that the pronunciation started as an
answer,
but it diverged and became different in
Korean and Japanese even though it's the
same two characters at some other
examples in Korean sap team in Japanese,
Shashi and photograph the were forcing
her in Korean.
In Japanese costumes.
The word for promise in Korean.
Yuck.
Sold in Japanese.
Yeah,
because so cute.
Those examples sound quite similar,
but sometimes they sound really quite
different,
but if we look at the romanized world,
sometimes we can see the similarities.
This is the word for telephone in Korean
children.
Wow.
In Japanese then?
Well,
so those come from the same characters,
but again,
they're rendered differently in
pronunciation.
The next word is school in Korean.
How you'll in Japanese got cold.
Another example is university in Korean,
in Japanese got Tofu in Korean to boot
in Japanese soul food.
The word for SPA or hot spring in
Korean.
On John,
in Japanese on sand.
So you can see that sometimes the words
are clearly related,
but when you're listening to the
language being spoken,
you probably wouldn't be able to catch
those words.
Chinese loan words aside.
There are also some Japanese loan words
that have entered the Korean language.
The word for cheers when you're having a
drink and Korean going pay in Japanese
come by.
The Japanese word for bag in Korean it's
in Japanese.
It's come on.
There are also a lot of words that are
native to both Korean and Japanese that
might be related to each other.
The word for island in Korean,
in Japanese Shima the word for village
in Korean.
In Japanese,
Buddha.
There are a lot of words like that that
I don't really think are connected,
but linguists think might be connected.
Interestingly though,
some of the grammatical particles have
very similar pronunciations in the two
languages.
For example,
the word for above.
In Korean we ate in Japanese who a
question particle co in Korean,
the double continent,
the Double Cup in.
In Japanese it's cut the word for two or
towards.
In Korean it's a and in Japanese it's a
the subject marker,
so this is different from the topic.
Margaret,
the subject marker is in Korean,
got for eat in Japanese,
it's just got so basically Korean and
Japanese have a lot of vocabulary that
are related but not the same.
It's probably enough to help you
remember that word if you study it,
but not necessarily enough to pick up
that word when you're hearing it in
conversation,
and of course most of the spoken
vocabulary seems to be unrelated or
they're words that have very ancient
connections to each other.
Now let's look at the different
pronunciation of the two languages.
In some ways they're similar.
The basic phonetic sounds of the two
languages are quite similar,
but the way those phonetic sounds are
arranged to create syllables is
different in the two languages.
In Japanese,
basically every syllable has to end in a
vowel.
You cannot have a word that ends in a
solid consonant like cut.
It has to be something like customer
with a vowel added to the end,
but in Korean you can have a consonant
at the end of a syllable.
That's why in one of the words that we
compared before the word promise,
in Japanese,
it's yet grew so poor.
You need those vowels after the
continence,
but in Korea,
and it's yet another difference is that
in Japanese,
the pronunciation of consonants doesn't
change depending on their position in
the word,
they just are always the same,
but in Korean there are consonants and
that can change depending on whether
they're at the beginning of the word in
the middle of the word or at the end of
the word.
Korean also has a greater variety of
vowels and diphthongs,
so in general,
Korean pronunciation is just more
complex than Japanese pronunciation.
One thing that is completely different
between the two languages is there
writing systems.
Japanese is written using a combination
of Chinese characters and two syllables.
Those is consist of characters that
represent entire syllables rather than
just individual phonetic sounds.
The Japanese writing system is quite
complex and since you need to learn more
than 2000 congee to be able to read at
an adult level,
it can take quite a lot of time and
effort to learn.
Korean,
on the other hand,
is written in the humble alphabet,
which is one of the simplest writing
systems in the world.
Korean used to use Han Chinese
characters in the same way that Japanese
uses congee and combination with Ido
gonna Kinda Kinda.
But they've done away with that and now
they're just using the simplified
writing system of humble,
humble.
Alphabet consists of individual phonetic
symbols that are arranged together to
create syllables.
In this example for hunch,
this is the sound for like an h.
This is the sound.
This is the sound for like an end.
This is the sound for a job for sure.
And this is ah,
so whereas Japanese requires you to
learn 92 syllabary symbols and 2000
congee in Korea and you just have to
learn 24 phonetic symbols and you can
use those to represent any new words
that you learned.
So to summarize,
Korean and Japanese are very similar in
terms of sentence structure and grammar
and they both have a large number of
Chinese loan words,
but the native vocabularies are quite
different as is the pronunciation which
makes these two languages mutually
unintelligible.
On top of that,
the two writing systems are now
completely different with the new modern
Korean system,
completely avoiding Chinese characters
these days.
My feeling is that Japanese and Korean
did originate from the same language a
very long time ago,
but they've been diverging for a long
time,
perhaps about 2000 years so that now
they're very different even though
structurally they're quite similar.
Thank you for watching the Lang focus
channels.
Leave your comments down below,
especially if you have studied Japanese
or Korean and you can let us know about
some other similarities or differences
that you have discovered.
Thank you for watching and have a nice
day.